There are much better
options than dropdowns.
Check the links in the instructor
notes if you still don't believe us.
After watching Cam having
terrible time with dropdowns,
you should be asking yourself,
how do I pick the right ones?
How do I decide what input to pick?
These are great questions.
Luckily the HTML five star includes
a number of input types tailored for
every situation.
You can find a link to the list
in the instructor notes.
Consider these the tools or
building blocks for your forms.
This should look pretty familiar.
Here is on the left is the phone input.
So here on the right is the Email and
in the middle you could see the URL.
And of course we have many more.
Notice how each specialized input
contains the buttons
that the user needs.
Nothing more, nothing less.
This is great because we don't have too
much real estate on a mobile device and
we want to enable our users
the most convenient way
to type the information they need.
In the next quizzes, Cam will challenge
you to research on your own and
pick the best input types for
your forms.